this video is about two factor analysis
of variance without repeated measures we
discuss what you need two factor
analysis of variance four and what the
difference is between one factor and two
factor dan will go over the hypotheses
and the assumptions after that i will
show you how to calculate the two factor
analysis of variance online with data
tab how to interpret the results and we
will also discuss what the interaction
effects are
finally we'll go over the formulas so
you can better understand what happens
in two-factor analysis of variants let's
get started
if we look at the most common types of
analysis of variance we distinguish
between the one factor and the two
factor analysis of variance and on the
other hand the analysis of variance
without repeated measures and with
repeated measures
this video is about the two-factor
analysis of variance without measurement
repetition this brings us to the first
question what do i need the
two-factorial analysis of variance four
the two factor analysis of variance
tests whether there is a difference
between more than two independent
samples divided between two variables or
factors
but what is the difference to the normal
one factor analysis of variance or what
is the difference between single
factorial and two factorial
let's start with the question of what a
factor actually is
a factor is for example the gender of a
person with the characteristics
male and female or
the form of therapy used for a disease
with therapy a b and c
or it could be the field of study with
for example medicine business
administration psychology and math
in the case of analysis of variance a
factor is therefore a categorical
variable
you use an analysis of variance whenever
you want to test whether these
categories have an influence on the
so-called dependent variable for example
you could test whether gender has an
influence on salary
whether the therapy has an influence on
the blood pressure or whether the field
of study has an influence on the
duration of study
salary blood pressure and study duration
are then the dependent variables in all
these cases you can now check whether
the factor has an influence on the
dependent variable since you only have
one factor in these cases
you could use a single factor analysis
of variance
you're right if you say well in the
first case we have a variable with only
two categories so of course we could use
the t-test for independent samples as
well
now of course you may say but i have
another categorical variable that may
also have an effect on the dependent
variable and i want to include
that variable as well
maybe you would also like to know if in
addition to gender the highest level of
education has an impact on salary or in
addition to the form of therapy maybe
you would also like to include gender
or in the third case you would also like
to know whether in addition to the field
of study the university attended also
has an influence on the length of study
now in these cases you would not have
one factor but two factors in each case
and since you now have two factors you
use the two factor analysis of variance
with the help of the two-factor analysis
of variance you can now answer three
things
once whether the first factor has an
influence on the dependent variable
once whether the second factor has an
influence on a dependent variable and
then you can also make a statement
whether there is a so-called interaction
effect between the two factors therefore
in the case of single factor analysis of
variance we have one factor from which
we create the groups in the case of the
two factor analysis of variance the
group results from the combination of
the expression of the two factors
if we have a factor or variable with
three expressions and one with two
expressions we get a total of six groups
that we want to compare
now we have a good transition to the
hypotheses
as already mentioned you can test three
statements with the two factorial
analysis of variance so there are also
three null hypotheses and therefore also
three alternative hypotheses
the first null hypothesis is there are
no significant differences between the
groups of the first factor then of
course there is the second one there are
no significant differences between the
groups of the second factor
and the third null hypothesis reflects
the interaction effect
one factor has no influence on the
effect of the other factor what this
interaction effect exactly means will be
discussed later in this video and in
addition there is the alternative
hypothesis which says in each case that
the factors have a significant influence
and in the case of the interaction
effect at least one factor has an
influence on the effect of the other
factor and with that we can now come to
the assumptions
let's first look at the scale level the
scale level of the dependent variable
should be metric that of the independent
variable the factors should be nominal
scale
so the dependent variable could be for
example salary blood pressure and the
study duration these are all metric
variables
and the independent variable should be
nominally or ordinarily scaled for
example gender high school degree or
type of a therapy note however that rank
order is not used for ordinal variables
so this information is lost
let's move on to the next assumption the
next assumption is about independence
the measurements should be independent
meaning that the measurement from one
group should not be influenced by the
measurement from another group
if this was the case we would need an
analysis of variance with repeated
measurements
the next topic is homogeneity
the variances in each group should be
approximately equal this can be checked
with the levine's test and finally the
last requirement which is about the
normal distribution the data within the
group should be normally distributed
with this i will now show you with an
example how to calculate the analysis of
variance online with data tab then we
will discuss how to interpret the
results and we will also talk about what
the interaction effects are exactly and
finally we will come to the formulas
let's take a quick look at an example
let's say you work in the marketing
department of a bank and you want to
find out whether gender and whether one
has studied or not has an influence on
the retirement planning so your two
independent variables or the two factors
are gender and whether one has studied
or not your dependent variable is
attitude towards retirement planning
where one means it's not important to me
and 10 means it is very important to me
after all is attitude toward retirement
planning really a metric variable let's
just assume that attitude toward
retirement planning was measured using a
likert scale and thus we consider the
resulting variable to be metric this
example consists of only 20 cases which
is of course not a lot so we have a very
low test power but as an example it
should be fine
to calculate a two-factor analysis of
variance online simply visit
datadept.net and copy your own data into
this table then you click on hypothesis
test under this tab you will find a lot
of hypothesis tests and depending on
which variable you click on you will get
an appropriate hypothesis test suggested
if you copy your data up here the
variables will appear down there
if the correct scale level is not
automatically detected you can simply
change it under variables view
we want to know if gender and whether
you have studied or not has an influence
on your attitude towards retirement
planning so let's just click on all
three variables
data that now automatically gives us a
two factor analysis of variance without
repeated measures
we can read the three
null and the three alternative
hypotheses here afterwards we get the
descriptive statistics and the levine
test of the variance equality with the
levine test you can check if the
variances within the groups are equal
the p-value is greater than
0.05
so we assume equality of variance in the
groups for this data
and here we see the results of the
analysis of variance we'll look at these
in more detail in a moment
but if you want to know exactly how to
interpret the results you can also just
click on the summary in words
in addition you can check here if the
assumptions for the analysis of variance
are met at all but now back to results
most important in this table are these
three rows
with these three rows you can test
whether the three null hypotheses we
formulated earlier are retained or
rejected the first row tests the null
hypothesis whether being a student or
not has an effect on the attitude
towards retirement planning the second
road test where the gender has an effect
on the attitude and the third row tests
the interaction between being a student
and gender you can read the p-value in
each case right here
let's assume we set the significance
level at five percent if our calculated
p-value is less than
0.05 then the null hypothesis is
rejected and if the calculated p-value
is greater than 0.05 then the null
hypothesis is retained
thus we see here that all three p-values
are greater than
0.05 and therefore we cannot reject any
of the three null hypotheses therefore
neither whether one has studied or not
nor gender has a significant effect on
the attitude towards retirement planning
and there is also no significant
interaction between having studied and
gender with respect to the attitude
towards retirement planning but what
exactly does interaction mean now we
will now go through this in more detail
to do this let's first take a look at
this diagram
the dependent variable is plotted on the
y-axis in our example the attitude
towards retirement planning on the
x-axis one of the two factors is plotted
let's just take gender the other factor
is represented by lines with different
colors green is studied and red is not
studied the endpoints of the lines are
respectively the mean values of the
groups so this point is the mean of male
and not studied this point is the mean
of male and studied and the same on the
other side for female therefore here you
can see that the male and studied group
has a higher mean than the male and not
studied group however you can also see
that the group of females each have a
higher mean than the group of males in
this chart one can see that both gender
and variable of whether one has studied
or not have an impact on the attitude
towards retirement planning
women have a higher value than men and
those who have studied have a higher
value than those who have not studied
however it can be seen that there is no
interaction between the two factors the
influence of gender on the attitude
towards retirement planning is
independent of the variable whether one
has studied or not and the other way
around the influence of the study status
on the attitude towards retirement
planning is independent of gender no
matter if male or female there's always
the same difference between studied and
not studied so whenever these lines are
parallel to one another there is no
interaction effect let's look at two
more cases where there is no interaction
effect in this case chandler has no
influence on the attitude towards
retirement planning and only study
status has an influence and there is
also no interaction effect in the next
case again whether one has studied or
not has no influence only gender has an
influence but now finally to the
interaction effects for that we compare
these two diagrams in the first case we
said there is no interaction effect if a
person has studied he or she has a value
that is say
1.5 higher than a person who has not
studied this increase of 1.5 is
independent of whether the person is
male or female we have a different
situation in this case here studied
people also have a higher value but how
much higher the value is depends on
whether one is male or female if i'm
male there is a difference of let's say
0.5 and if i'm female there's a
difference of 3.5 so in this case we
clearly have an interaction between
gender and study because the two
variables influence each other it makes
a difference how strong the influence of
studying is depending on whether i'm
male or female in this case we have an
interaction effect but the direction
still remains the same so women have
higher values than men and studied
people have higher values than people
who did not study of course one could
also get the following results in this
case studying would have no influence at
all on man but only on women so the mean
value is exactly the same for men
regardless of whether these people have
studied or not or let's look at an even
more extreme case in this case
man would have a higher value for those
who have not studied and women would
have a higher value for those who have
studied so now let's go into the
formulas needed to calculate an analysis
of variance
what does the analysis of variance
actually do or why is the word variance
actually in the analysis of variance in
analysis of variance the total variance
of the dependent variable is divided
into the variance of vector a and b and
the variance of the interaction and the
error variance
what does that mean
the independent variable under
consideration has some variance in our
example not every person will have the
same attitude towards retirement
planning some people will regard it as
more important and others will say well
that's less important to me we now want
to know if this variable depends on the
variable's gender and study status so we
want to know if we can explain some of
the variance by the variable gender
study status and also by their
interaction the portion that we cannot
explain by these three aspects then
accumulate in the error ss stands for
sum of squares
if the result would look like this for
example we would be able to explain
almost the entire variance through
factors a and b and their interaction
and we would only have a very small
proportion that could not be explained
this would mean that we can make a very
good statement about the attitude
towards retirement planning purely
through the variable gender and study
status and their interaction
in this case it would be the other way
around here gender study status and the
interaction has no influence at all on
the attitude towards retirement planning
and everything accumulates in the error
perhaps age has an influence or place of
residence or quite a few other variables
but we don't know that it all
accumulates in the error
now comes the big question how do we
calculate the different sums of squares
we will now go through this using our
example here we have our data once not
studied and studied and once male and
female first we calculate the mean
values we need we calculate the mean
value of the individual groups thus of
male and not studied that is 5.8
then of male and studied which is
5.4 and we do the same now for female
then we calculate the mean value of all
men and women and the mean value of
non-students and students
finally we need the total mean value
with this we can now start and calculate
the required sums of squares let's start
with the total sum of squares for this
we calculate each individual value minus
the total mean square this and sum up
all values the total mean is
5.4 so we calculate 6 minus 5.4 squared
plus 4 minus 5.4 squared to finally 3
minus 5.4 squared
together with the sum of squares and the
degrees of freedom we can then calculate
the total variance
the degrees of freedom here are given by
n times p
times q
minus 1. n is the number of people in a
group which is five in our case and p
and q are the number of categories in
each factors we have in both cases two
groups male and female or not started
and studied with that p and q in our
case is 2. thus we receive for the
degrees of freedom
19. the total variance results with the
square sum divided by the number of
degrees of freedom so we get
4.46 now we can calculate the sum of
squares between
for this we calculate the group mean
minus the total mean so 5.8
minus 5.4 squared plus 5.4 minus 5.4
squared and the same for these two
values in this case the degrees of
freedom are 3 which gives us a variance
of 2.53
now we can calculate the sum of squares
of factor a and b
we do that with this formula a dash is
the mean value of the categories of
factor a so we calculate 5.9 minus the
total mean value and 4.9 minus the total
mean value together with the degrees of
freedom we can now calculate the
variance for factor a we do the same for
factor b in this case we use the mean
values of male and female and we get a
variance of
0.8 now we can calculate the sum of
squares for the interaction
we obtain this by calculating the sum of
squares between
minus the sum of squares of a
minus the sum of squares of b
for the interaction we get a variance of
1.8
now we have almost done it finally we
can calculate the sum of squares for the
error
this is calculated similar to the total
sum of squares so again we use each
individual value only in this case we do
not subtract the total mean from each
value but we subtract the respective
group mean from each value
so in this group we subtract
5.8 from each individual value
in that group we subtract 5.4
here we subtract 6 and then we subtract
4.4 so we get 6 minus 5.8 squared plus 4
minus 5.4 squared to finally 3
minus 4.4 squared this gives us a sum of
squares of
77.2 and the variance of
4.83 and now we can calculate the f
values
these are obtained by dividing the
variance of factor a b
or the interaction
by the arrow variance so we get the f
value for factor a by dividing the
variance of a by the arrow variance
which equals
1.04 we can now do exactly the same for
f b
and f a b
to verify we get exactly the same values
with data tab
1.04
0.17 and 0.37
for the calculation of the p-value you
need the degrees of freedom and the f
distribution so with these three values
you can either read the critical p-value
in a table or as usual
you just use a software to calculate the
p-values i hope you enjoyed the video
and see you next time